what we keep hearing from lots of people
which is what do I do when it comes for
me right I think the answer can't be it
can't be an individual answer it's not
going to work and what I have begun to
observe is that there's certain
environments online where you can't
navigate this stuff and then there are
others where the structure of the
environment itself allows you to so on
reddit for example reddit is now a
disaster for many reasons but inside of
a subreddit many people can talk about
what's going on and most of the users
are anonymous just by virtue of the way
it works and so my point would be I
think that people who understand that
there's something wrong about the
ideology that's marketing
through our our national landscape and
appending structures on which we are
depending that those people need to be
able to find each other and they need to
be able to have a conversation that
functions as a reality check at first
and that reality check is the key
ingredient to be able to maintain your
bearing that is to say when it comes for
you it's going to be very hard to resist
the mob and what it insists is true in
terms of your defects and it's going to
be very hard not to say the things that
it wants you to say I would advise you
not to say those things but it's not
gonna be possible for everybody people
have livelihoods they have to maintain
people have children they have to
protect but if you can find a community
that is capable of barring that set of
kafka traps and you can check in with it
and you can say look I had to go to this
training in order to retain my job and I
can't afford to give up my job but
here's what was said at this training
and here's why I find it absurd and
somebody else can say you know I saw the
very same thing and here's what I
thought that reality check that allows
people who are trying to resist this to
just simply not be each of us alone but
to find each other
compare notes and then eventually to
discover things that work what can you
say when somebody says one of these
things that actually causes the script
to change that diverts it for a moment
the
detains it that causes it to have to
answer questions that it should have to
answer I believe in there is the seeds
of a solution in which we stop playing
defense which isn't working and we start
playing offense which will yeah and and
you can start collecting people this way
right people who are listening here
presumably already already know most of
this and probably many of you are being
forced to sit in on these trainings to
participate maybe even to identify your
own internal racism whatever maybe you
are in a place where you can speak up we
would hope so
find a place online where you can do
exactly what Brett is talking about and
then go back to the next training may be
a bit emboldened with an idea of how you
can say something how you can just lodge
an idea lodge a criticism that even if
it is not even if it does not make clear
to the people organizing the training or
the or the true believers that you are
in fact lodging a complaint those other
people among your colleagues who also
don't respect what is going on will hear
it and probably at least one of them
will come to you quietly privately and
say yeah me too
at which point you invite them in to
whatever online community you have and
say listen in on this then let us figure
out if we can generate ideas and tools
with which to fight off this thing this
ideology which is not about anti racism
and it's not about inclusivity and it's
not about diversity it is quite the
opposite and then next time you go to a
training again maybe they're now two of
you one person stands up in a row of 30
you'll get shouted down as you did
alright as you did Brett but two people
there's a better chance three people
what's the tipping point there will be
some tipping point there will be some
tipping point and it's going to change
it's not going to be a flat percentage
in a room of 30 versus a room of 300
it's not going to be 10% in both places
but there is some number of people in a
room that says you know what no
me critiquing the work of someone is not
racist based on whether or not they have
black skin or not no everyone gets to be
critiqued everyone gets to be
congratulated and focusing on the color
of the skin of the person who I'm
critiquing is actually the racist thing
not the other way around absolutely and
as you pointed out when we initially
started exploring this is a solution one
of the things that is sure to happen if
you check in with your online
environment which you may have to create
it may be a slack or a discord or
something you create an environment
where you can safely talk and you can
establish the rules for people coming in
you know good honorable IDW kind of
rules but once you do that and you
establish your reality check and you
figure out what you can say in a
training that will advertise that maybe
you're not quite fully on board you will
find people will come to you and they
will say thank you thank you for doing
that right when you know who those
people are who hear what you're saying
and wish that they were saying it too
you can invite them into these
communities and they can get their
reality check and what that means is
that you will ultimately form a group of
people who understands that something
that isn't desirable is afoot and you
can start figuring out how to back each
other up and you will become safer so I
think that really is the route to a
solution yeah so you said something to
me a week or more ago that you haven't
yet set on air so I'm gonna say it and
see if you want a trip just just briefly
before we we have a number of
announcements and then go to break
before we come back for the QA we should
all be pursuing the moment when if we
were in a movie the hero music would be
playing right we all recognize it when
it happens in the movies we know when
that music is about to start playing and
we know what the character what we want
the character to do we know we want to
be we do so
how do we attain that in life yeah we
all know the soundtrack if they reverse
the soundtrack of the villain and the
hero you'd be like what the hell kind of
movie is this what is this right so we
all know what it is that feels good and
we really all know or most of us know
what's right and so to the extent that's
something that is very much not right is
afoot the question is what you know what
does the hero do what is that you know
the person gives the awful fascist
speech and the you know the hero in the
back row does that slow clap thing that
reveals that he's just not buying it bad
thing the question is how do you get to
that scene in the movie what needs to be
true in order for you to pull that off
[Music]